welcome to this video I'm playing he's
so cool yeah mr. so Colin I have really
bad scoring and slack and from very good
positions it's what I remember but
anyway you have sometimes you have those
kind of mismatches where it's um it's
just not working somehow ok on i can go
nite be three down
9 p-3 I'm going a 4 also he's putting
this back there voluntarily
okay taking anti pusher c5 next
yeah that's a bad bone structure but a
pair of push-ups let's see Bishop e6
immediately this one idea I guess so he
will go v3 know ok ok let's go therefore
be five I thought okay bye be five years
bishops is six ok to become one word
that I'm really good at overlooking off
but it's not really necessary to go
waveform here still playing for b5 he
somehow does not do anything against it
may be 94 is this idea let's cover that
I thought a four is good here and this
yo Keem the captcha didn't didn't lead
to that much really didn't and here here
interesting i can go Bishop d7 and again
be five maybe that's not so bad and
steward and not go I mean that the clock
time I mean maybe I lost all those game
against gains against him on the clock i
don't know i only remember that it
wasn't very pleasant experience I mean
it really is if you lose but there are
there are games that you lose that
really really feel awkward sometimes you
just think okay played well when can you
do I don't have that particular memory
with those games or is it still a
blunder the pawn down out of this
nothing position maybe
not very stupid and entirely unnecessary
okay will be six and wait not too quick
group with six tix okay aight i'm not
catching this bishop
prolly still have to a rock c5 is
playing in San I'm a gap anyway anyway
so lock in this form for the moment but
only for the moment unfortunately then
you can come over there
now it's just bad just bad
now that end game was completely okay
for black really was but I played it
badly time warning before as a strange
move but maybe it still ok
Joe even with rooks traded it's probably
difficult to hold and I mean I'm not
exactly close to trading books
check okay a lap resign I know sometimes
you have people you cannot really get
anything going yeah I mean there's
something simply nothing going on here
but this knight c6 is just good it's
just good can probably take on default
something like that or I should avoid be
five maybe this is the way to do it I
mean I can really just sit here White
has no way forward in this position
anyway what exactly is he doing yes no
porn break but I wanted to do something
and it didn't it didn't really help mmm
yeah I just I didn't see with 96 simply
this is the problem when I went back
here and now I'm losing that a porn it's
just basically a blunder upon and not
much else Jim after that and it's really
it's really useless the position is lost
him I cannot really avoid him getting
the B porn in motion later I made a
mistake as an opening act by the way I
have to start with 85 here after
cancelling I mean okay I'm didn't make a
mistake ready what he did is it's not
leading to anything of course
I just have to play it better like here
h six or so preventing Bishop g5 I mean
okay the endgame is no problem it's just
that it's a little bit it's not very
interesting to play White has I mean why
can just stay here with this with the
structure okay well thanks for watching